so i'm tristan and my job
involves a lot of staring at large
tables of numbers
and often i want to do something like
look at this column of latency numbers
in nanoseconds
and pick out some larger quantity like
microseconds and milliseconds
and this used to involve counting a lot
of digits starting from the right of the
number
and i found myself doing this in all
sorts of different places
like my text editor and my terminal
and python notebooks in my web browser
and
i didn't want to implement a solution
for each of these places
but i came up with a weird solution that
would work in all of these places
which is i could make a font that would
insert fake commas into my numbers
and i could do this using font shaping
or at least i thought i could
because font shaping was really powerful
and i had seen all sorts of examples of
really beautiful calligraphy
and fancy unicode tricks of various
sorts
and so i have some examples here that i
made by
fooling around with the unicode
character palette for far too long like
this face here
made by combining characters to arrange
things on top of each other
and so i thought i could do it so i
looked into the open type font shaping
specification
which defines how all these things work
and so it says that
things proceed in various stages
controlled by tables within the font
so first the characters in the string
are mapped to glyphs which are internal
uh things used by the font and then
glyph substitution rules and the g sub
table are ran on them
so these replace various sequences of
glyphs with various other sequences of
glyphs
for example to do ligatures by combining
glyphs together
into a specialized literature then
this sequence of glyphs that's had
substitution applied to it
goes to the glyph positioning step and
what this does
is it positions glyphs on top of each
other um
in the correct location so that your
accents are for example
above or below the character and at this
point everything is still just internal
ids used by the font
and it needs to be rendered by the ui
system and in this case it needs to be
translated to outlines
and these outlines for each glyph are
stored in a table inside the font
and i was reading through this
specification and i started to get a
little worried
because everything seems to work from
the start of the string
towards the end of the string and i
needed to work from the end of the
number towards the beginning of the
number
luckily at the very end i found the
reverse chaining contextual single
substitution rule
and what this rule does is it acts kind
of like
a certain type of regular expression
where uh everything is a glyph class
and glyph classes are kind of like regex
character classes
where they match a set of glyphs that
can be in a specific position
so there's the single position to
replace
and a class of possible glyphs there and
replacements for each of them
as well as look ahead and backtracking
classes that match various
uh positions around that glyph and this
rule type was originally designed for a
type of arabic calligraphy
and it was actually meant for doing left
to
right shaping on that type of arabic
calligraphy but arabic calligraphy
is a right to left context so in order
to do left to right it has to work from
the end of the string to the beginning
of the string
so in my left to right context that's
exactly what i wanted it would work
right to left
so font designers don't actually use uh
the tables directly because there's some
binary format they use a language called
font feature files which compiles down
to the tables
and here i have an example file
it has glyph class definitions at the
top for lowercase and uppercase vowels
it says a feature that i want my rules
in these are just
used for applying things in different
orders or
disabling and enabling things and then
it has my rules my first rule takes
finds a lowercase character next to
another lowercase character
and turns it into an uppercase character
the next rule takes
an uppercase character next to an
uppercase character and turns it into a
lowercase character
and because these are reverse chaining
they start from the
end of my string and make it so that
there's no two
cases next to each other and so they
alternate starting from whatever was at
the end
and this kind of alternating
capitalization is kind of like
counting modulo 2 from the end of the
string by using two different glyph sets
and we want to count digits from the end
of the number
and we can use a very similar technique
by using
different glyph sets but we only have
one set of number glyphs so what we need
to do
is create extra copies of the digit
glyphs
so that we can keep this state because
the only type of state
in this uh substitution is by replacing
glyphs so we need as many glyph sets
as we need to count glyphs
and as a digression i decided that at
first i didn't want to insert commas i
wanted to underline alternating groups
of three digits and the reason
is that i wanted this to work in my
terminal which is a monospace context
where every character has to be the same
length
and inserting commas would mess up the
fixed width tables and things like that
so in order to do this alternating
underlining i needed to count modulo of
six
because that's the periodicity of this
alternating groups of three digits
pattern
so i needed six different glyph sets
meaning i needed to add five extra ones
so this is how the first version of
number to line worked the first
character on the right of the number had
no rules applied to it staying as
effectively glyphs at zero
and then the next character after it had
a reverse sub rule
that matched a normal digit following a
normal digit and turned it into a glyphs
set one digit
another character over a rule matched
saying that a normal digit next to a
glyphs at one digit gets replaced with
glyphs at two digit
and this chaining pattern matches uh
continues over the first six digits and
then the seventh digit isn't matched by
any rule and so stays as
glyphs at zero digit and thus if i added
more digits the pattern would just
repeat
and now that i have all my glyphs mapped
to different glyph sets
i can then modify the outlines that are
in the glyph table
uh to change the style of some of these
glyph sets so in this case
i add an underline to glyph sets five
four and three
and this gives me my alternating
underlining at least in theory
now i have to actually write code for it
and to do this i had heard of this thing
called the powerline font patcher which
adds extra characters to a font which is
kind of what i wanted so it was a good
starting point
except for the fact that the font
library used crashed as soon as i tried
to use a reverse sub rule
and the reason is that it turns out
nobody uses these reverse sub rules even
for the type of
arabic calligraphy they're originally
intended for so they're broken in a few
different places
luckily i did find a font library that
did work and so i had my tables that
finally had underlyings
and alternating groups of three digits
making them easier to read
and so i went back to my original goal
and i implemented
fake commas by making some glyph sets
wider and inserting a comma into the
outline
i squished glyphs together to make this
kind of visual grouping
and then i inserted little commas in
between so i could have commas even in
mono's face contexts
did other fonts things like bolding and
then put them on a website for people to
download and wrote a blog post
and someone saw this blog post and took
it even further and wrote an
implementation of fizzbuzz
where it just adds numbered list
elements and
these kind of magically become uh the
correct fizzbuzz things and it does this
by implementing
the divisibility rules for three and
five that are based on the digits of the
number
as font shaping rules and then basically
implementing ligatures to replace those
uh i thought this was super cool but i
finally had uh
underlines in all my places like my
pandas notebooks at work
and this was great now you might think
this is a horrifying hack right
and i don't actually think it is i think
i'm kind of using font shaping for
something that it's intended for
or or the same kind of thing in terms of
it's
taking a raw representation of the text
and applying stylistic rules to make it
more easy to read and visually pleasing
and that's exactly the kind of thing
that font champion is designed for
it's kind of hacky insofar as i'm using
it on ascii characters that nobody
expects font shaping to be applied to
so various apps sometimes do performance
optimizations to disable font shaping
for
latin characters like sublime text nine
term two so i had to switch terminals to
kitty
uh to get it to work but when it does
work it actually works really well and
quite seamlessly including
like not having the fake commas when you
copy the text
so i think this is actually pretty good
and i think it's a cool example of
what you can do when you dive into a new
level of the system that you might not
have looked at before
and find the right level to implement
things i could have done it in some kind
of way involving some ansi pattern
matcher
to work just in my terminal or a browser
plug-in but i would have had to
implement multiple different things and
it just wouldn't have worked very well
and it actually would have been harder
to do
even after the time i spent researching
font shaping so
i urge you to go and dive in and
understand new areas of the system that
you haven't seen before
thanks that's all i have